[Música]
y el amor romántico tan hermoso y
embriagador desgarrador y rompecorazones
y al menudo todo eso al mismo tiempo
porque elegimos sufrir todo ese
torbellino emocional da el amor sentido
a nuestra vida o se trata de una vía de
escape de nuestra soledad y sufrimiento
es el amor un disfraz del deseo sexual o
un truco biológico para hacernos
procrear es todo lo que necesitamos de
hecho no lo necesitamos si el amor
romántico tiene un propósito ni la
ciencia ni la psicología lo han
descubierto todavía pero a lo largo de
la historia algunos de los filósofos más
respetados han propuesto teorías
fascinantes
el amor nos devuelve a la vida el
antiguo filósofo griego platón exploró
la idea de que amamos para sentirnos
completos en su simposio describe una
cena a la que aristófanes un
comediógrafo entretiene a los huéspedes
con la siguiente historia
los humanos fueron una vez criaturas con
cuatro brazos cuatro piernas y dos caras
un día enojaron a los dioses y zeus los
cortó a todos en dos desde entonces cada
persona ha estado buscando a su mitad el
amor es el deseo de encontrar un alma
gemela que nos haga sentir completos o
al menos es lo que platón creía que un
cómico borracho diría en una fiesta
el amor nos engaña para tener bebés
mucho mucho más tarde el filósofo alemán
arthur schopenhauer mantuvo la idea de
que el amor basado en el deseo sexual es
una ilusión atractiva
sugirió que amamos porque nuestros
deseos nos llevan a creer que la otra
persona nos hará felices pero estamos
muy equivocados la naturaleza nos está
engañando para que pro creemos y la
unión amorosa que buscamos cobra vida en
nuestros hijos después de satisfacer
nuestros deseos sexuales volvemos a
vivir nuestras existencias atormentadas
de forma que sólo logramos mantener
nuestra especie y perpetuar el ciclo de
la monotonía humana
aparentemente alguien necesita un abrazo
el amor es el escape a nuestra soledad
según el ganador del premio nobel el
filósofo británico bertrand rosso amamos
para saciar nuestros deseos físicos y
psicológicos los seres humanos estamos
diseñados para procrear pero sin el
éxtasis del amor apasionado el sexo no
llena
el miedo hacia este mundo frío y cruel
nos tienta atrincherarnos para
protegernos y aislarnos los placeres del
amor la intimidad y la calidez nos
ayudan a superar el miedo que tenemos al
mundo escapar de nuestros mundos
solitarios y disfrutar de la alegría de
la vida
el amor nos enriquece y es lo mejor de
la vida el amor es una aflicción
engañosa
siddharta gautama también conocido como
buda o el iluminado probablemente
hubiera tenido discusiones interesantes
con ross o duda dijo que amamos porque
tratamos de satisfacer los deseos más
elementales sin embargo estos deseos
apasionados son defectos y el cariño
incluso el amor romántico son una gran
fuente de sufrimiento por suerte buda
descubrió el camino de ocho partes un
tipo de programa para apaciguar el deseo
para llegar al nirvana un estado elevado
de paz claridad lleno de sabiduría y
compasión el novelista show switching
ilustró este sentimiento budista de que
el amor romántico es una locura en una
de las novelas clásicas de china sueño
en el pabellón rojo
en una subtrama jan rey se enamora de
shift en que le engaña y le humilla
emociones mezcladas de amor y odio le
rompen el corazón por lo que un ko ista
le da un espejo mágico que puede curarlo
siempre y cuando no mire el espejo de
frente pero por supuesto el mira y ve
asif en su alma queda atrapada en el
espejo y es condenado a morir encadenado
no todos los budistas piensan lo mismo
acerca del amor romántico y erótico pero
la moraleja de esta historia es que esta
manera de encariñarse sólo provoca
tragedias y debe por ende junto con los
espejos mágicos evitarse el amor nos
permite ir más allá de nosotros mismos
acabemos con una nota ligeramente más
positiva la filósofa francesa simon de
beauvoir propuso que el amor es el deseo
de unirse y que da sentido a nuestras
vidas sin embargo le preocupaba menos la
razón por la que amamos y le interesaba
más como amar mejor
vio que el problema del amor romántico
tradicional es que puede ser tan
cautivador que queramos hacerlo nuestra
única razón de ser
[Música]
sin embargo depender del otro para
justificar nuestra existencia lleva
fácilmente al aburrimiento y a juegos de
poder para evitar esta trampa vevo a
aconsejo amar de verdad algo que se
parece más bien a una gran amistad los
amantes se apoyan mutuamente al
descubrirse a sí mismos al ir más allá
de sí mismos y enriquecer sus vidas y
las del mundo juntos
aunque puede que nunca sepamos por qué
nos enamoramos podemos estar seguros de
que conlleva una montaña rusa emocional
es aterrador y estimulante nos hace
sufrir y nos hace volar tal vez perdamos
la cabeza tal vez descubramos quiénes
somos puede que te parta el corazón o
puede que sea lo mejor que te pasó en la
vida te atreves a descubrirlo
enamorado de td en español asegúrese de
suscribirse a nuestro canal y no se
pierda ninguna animación manténgase
conectado tenga curiosidad
[Música]